[Music]
my parents had started a weekly date
night habit of going to the theater and
dining at Joe Allen on 46th Street
afterwards my twin brother hunter and I
had rounded out the children of our
lower middle-income family and so a
night out on the town was a rare luxury
for my parents who were probably trying
to connect with one another and
themselves no small feat for parents of
for living in New York City shared a
very touching tribute to your mom which
was so beautiful how proud is she of you
and getting us honored tonight I really
couldn't think of anybody else that I'd
rather be with me here tonight than my
mother Melanie who you know it's been
incredibly inspiring for me in many many
many many ways so I couldn't imagine a
better date than my mother tonight
you're such an amazing mom yourself what
have you learned from your mom in terms
of lessons and co-parenting I don't
profess to know anything about parenting
that anything more than anybody else
being a working mom is it's incredible
it's an incredible challenge it's an
incredible gift and I think you will
always feel a little bit of guilt you
never know you know whether your
you're at work you feel like you're
missing out on those special moments
with your kid if you're with your Cape
you feel like you're not giving enough
to your job but you know it's about a
lot of like huge admiration and respect
for working moms I'm barely barely
holding it together
[Music]
you